Yes, sir?
I'd like to have an argument, please.
Certainly, sir. Have you been here before?
No, this is my first time.
I see. Do you want to have the full argument or were you thinking of taking a course?
Well, what would be the cost?
Well, yes. It's one pound for a five minute argument, but only eight pounds for a course of ten.
Well, I think it's probably best if I start with the one and see how it goes from there, okay?
Fine, I'll see who's free at the moment. Try Mr. Barnard, room 12.
Thank you.
Come in.
Is this the right room for an argument?
I've told you once.
No, you haven't.
Yes, I have.
When?
Just now.
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
You didn't.
I did.
I'm telling you, I did.
You did not.
I'm sorry, is this a five minute argument or the full half hour?
Oh oh! Just the five minute one.
Fine. Thank you. Anyway, I did.
You most certainly did not.
Now, let's get one thing quite clear. I most definitely told you.
You did not.
I did.
Didn't.
Yes, I did.
Look, this isn't an argument.
Yes, it is.
No, it isn't. It's just contradiction.
No, it isn't.
Yes, it is.
It is not.
It is. You just contradicted me.
No, I didn't.
Oh, you did.
No, no, no, no.
You did just there.
Nonsense!
Oh look, this is futile.
No, it isn't.
I came here for good argument.
No, you didn't. You came here for an argument.
Well, argument is not the same as contradiction.
Can be.
No, it can't.
An argument is a connected series of statements to establish a definite proposition.
No, it isn't.
Yes, it is. It isn't just contradiction.
Look, if I argue with you, I must take up a contrary position.
But it isn't just saying "No, it isn't".
Yes, it is.
No, it isn't.
Argument is an intellectual process.
Contradiction is just the automatic gainsaying of anything the other person says.
No, it isn't.
Yes, it is.
Not at all.
Now, look.
Thank you. Good morning!